okay
so now that you've had some time to sit
with it how are you feeling about being
evicted
oh i feel great
[Laughter]
honestly i i do i feel great i'm just
happy that i had this experience and
i'm i'm not in the big brother house
anymore
it's bittersweet
um
you know julie showed you the alliance
who formed who was
once who essentially got you out
obviously they were able to get others
to flip the vote um was there someone or
something about that alliance that
surprised you or surprised you the most
not at all i put two and two together
early in the week and i
i knew that there was something else
cooking up and i i know that you know
michael definitely tried to look out for
me and he tried to drop hints and i just
wasn't picking them up
um
looking back on it do you
wish that you guys hadn't used the veto
or do you still feel like it was a move
worth making
i'm 50 50 on that you know big risk big
reward but at the same time
if there was any point that i could have
believed anything that was coming out of
monty's mouth
i would have definitely been trying to
convince daniel not to use the power of
veto
it's hard it's like a big brother
everyone lies but then it's like when
someone's telling you like don't do it
you're like but you want me to do it so
right exactly
it's hard um you know obviously we saw
um julie mention it and we you know
uh turner kind of hinted at it at his
speech a couple weeks ago
um that there's been sort of
mistreatment and bullying of taylor i
mean i sort of want to get your thoughts
on that and if you have any sort of
regrets about how
uh you treated taylor
um
i definitely do regret how i treated
taylor i think that i um
had a hand in giving her the short end
of the stick and i wish that i could go
back but you know i
take full ownership of things that were
said and done and i look forward to
looking back on all of it and being able
to
um sit with taylor and really go over
all those things and moving forward
hopefully we have a beautiful friendship
and that we can really work and i can
learn from a lot of what happened
yeah that was my next question was if
you had plans or had a desire to speak
with taylor after everything
absolutely um you know we've
i told her i loved her before i left and
i truly mean that we were holding hands
in the nomination chair before i was
evicted
um
you know those are those are true
feelings and
i i want to be better moving forward and
i want to be better with her moving
forward so yeah
do you feel like sort of how you know
julia mentioned it in her speech or
sorry in her interview with you that um
you know this alliance sort of formed
after the whole big fight with daniel
and all of that kind of stuff do you
feel like sort of how things went down
with taylor is why not the only reason
obviously but part of the reason you got
evicted
yes
yeah what other reasons do you think was
it uh that you think that you ended up
on the outside of that house
um i thought that i can control and
manipulate somebody else's game and i
put taylor i picked taylor as my festy
bestie because i thought i could use her
as a shield and
i was going by the words of my alliance
members and saying that she's the target
and that's what it comes down to is that
i was trying to advance my game so
strategically i figured
bringing her as close as i could to me
that that would make that happen
um what surprised you the most about
playing big brother
i mean
it's exhausting
campaigning for yourself and trying to
trying to promise things to people that
you know you can't promise anything to
any of these people um
but
the
the mental exhaustion is is real and
you
i wasn't
expecting what the totality of that was
going to be
at what point um
did you realize that you were
probably like
most definitely going home i mean did
you think even towards the end that
there was a chance or did you kind of
accept it by the time you were sitting
on the eviction block
i
i accepted it the moment i was sitting
on the block but i knew that i wasn't
going to give up
and i think that that showed through
until
five minutes before i sat in that
nomination chair before the live show
um who do you think um you know
obviously there's still a lot of game
left to be played um and you haven't
obviously watched the stuff but who do
you think is going to go far in this
game based off just the information you
have right now
michael i want michael to win this game
i want michael to go all the way i want
him sitting in that chair and i really
do hope that these
whoever's in the jury that they make
that happen